after September 11th when Bob Moeller
became the FBI director and the
transition to the intelligence agency
that you now see through its full
fruition began and the people that came
in under Mueller in the early days
they're now in a position of leadership
in the FBI so they came in it's very
Patriot Act neocon mindset that maybe
inspired them to join then Comey comes
in and he brought in the I'm ethical
beyond all reproach and and unethical I
I am at the ethical and I I I think the
story is that the his lieutenants and
the folks that were around him and are
now ascending these very high levels
they were called the College of
cardinals because they are True
Believers in their utmost morality you
cannot question they've never sat looked
in the mirror and said am I the bad guy
and now they are the executive assistant
director what an arrogant way of doing
things oh my God that's disgusting